pour toutes vos dédicaces personnalisées
n'hésitez pas à me contacter je les
ferai avec grand plaisir
vincent mcdoom
arriver loana c'est loana bravo loi n'a
absolument l'onac et sur un site où
effectivement pour les rémunérer pour la
toile a cédé site rémunéré 60 euros je
crois même voilà c'est soit la personne
qui donne le chiffre fait entre 25
euros/mois génériques et next - 20 euros
regardez pas ce qu'ils leur attitude on
a la liste d'aider des gens je ne juge
pas pour longtemps mais on va faire tout
à l'heure on analystes d'aider des gens
voilà les prix par vidéo voilà alors que
tu le fais non non non non non non je
dis c'est que on me l'a proposé ya
quelques semaines j'ai dit non mais ce
qui m'a super vexé c'est de savoir que
j'étais au bruit d'avion
sans déconner non mais c'est votre ami
c'est pas le problème ah oui d'accord
bien mais à quel point une carrière
merde tu vois et allons viser pourquoi
tu as refusé à ben pour le prime on
reçoit toujours
tard allait trouver que c'est immoral
c'est une question de prix ont fait toi
ça serait payé plus cher tu ne ferais
pas du tout
mais qui existe aussi il ya des sols
nancy si loana avait un premier tarif ça
fonctionnait pas assez alors à la
baisser un petit peu le tarif est un jeu
qui serait un guerrier saison mais le
site en question la prose à plat non
je leur ai proposé alors aussi
des acteurs non mais c'est complètement
ridicule vidéo c'est alors c'est délicat
il faut quand même savoir que ça peut
monter jusqu'à l'ailé moi évidemment de
noël tout ça parce que aussi beaucoup
d'entreprises autres mais se paye plus
cher un lait 1500 euros pour certains
certains fera la comédien ou ou
émetteurs télé ça peut monter jusqu'à 10
15000 euros par mois les très gros mot
argentan noël les moments et des fêtes
les saint valentin justement à la housse
est très demandé alors je sais pas avant
de savoir ça vous choque ou pas je vous
dis pas c'est une petite par exemple
regarder ça là on à vincent mcdoom qui
fait 1 je dédicace à hugo mano ce
que vous verrez bien jolie miss ou hugo
manon et finira pas de fred qui espère
que tu passes une
le noël au soleil on te souhaite une
belle gueule aztèque ça porte bonheur
[Applaudissements]
j'avais mis dans ma story un screenshot
où je me moquais justement de ce concept
là et du coup j'ai un défouloir que je
ne connais pas un cas que je ne connais
pas qu'à pied a fait cette demande qui
accueillirent pour le faire la blague et
qui document envoyé ça et on voit
vincent qui lit sans même comprendre ce
qu'ils y cèdre
alors comme dirait ce que vous en pensez
parce que c'est là évidemment elle
concerne quelqu'un quelques retours de
la table lui la peur de rien ça peut
être pour un anniversaire une parmi de
va un mariage un divorce ou un salon de
coiffure c'est jean-michel mer
plage de biarritz voilà c'est mon coin
familial et que j'adore et pour vous
dire que j'adhère on pourra me dont si
vous voulez des vidéos personnalité
envoyez moi un message dit fois toutes
les informations je vous fasse un petit
chose aux petits oignons et voilà et en
plus vous ferez une bonne action sous je
reverserai les fonds à la spa a
notamment inscrit à bayonne dont je suis
le parrain et aulas c'est une cause qui
me tient à coeur avec d'autres voilà je
vous embrasse trafford demandez moi ce
que vous voulez je ferai dans la mesure
du possible et mes moyens
gentil pour donner parce que vous êtes
salut c'était un coiffeur à besançon
salut je voulais te dire que ben pour 60
qu'au fur je souhaite le meilleur
j'espère que tu rabat plein clients pour
les coiffures des brushings
[Musique]
match le plus important c'est pas pour
moi je n'osais la sp1 sa
mère il certaines vidéos je refuse qu'un
à certains qu'ils veulent et qui
s'invente une vie donc c'est bon pour
noël j'avais quelqu'un qui ment vie de
l'île ont formé une vidéo quand on vois
pour ma femme faisant quoi désolé mon
chat je peux pas venir pour noël j'ai
adoré faire la surprise à tes parents
qu'on est potes extra des gens qui se
mitonne comme ça là je refuse pas être
vos journaux vidéo je refuse la après
l'orage au 6 impasse des gens que tu
passe pas par une par une boîte
sélection pour les surverses la totalité
excuses natalité est important de le
constater ci car on est en vie de deux
enfants et deux ou trois par mois donc
c'est pas non plus des sommes suis
désolé espère oui c'est tout moi
centaines d'euros par mois et oui c'est
ça on pige à une partie des prises par
le site savez après franchement tu
pourrais prendre de tes non je n'ai non
c'est comme ça ça me coûterait je fais
la vidéo c'est les gens qui donnent pour
laisse moi ben oui c'est ça alors pour
ceux qui donnent pas la spa tout ça ça
ne choque toi finale alors moi ça me
choque pas du tout pour moi c'est comme
le au même titre que le placement de
produit en fait c'est du placement de
personnes ça fait plaisir aux gens
qu'ils demandent c'est dit aux gens qui
payent et puis portable et d'argent et
toi moi ça me choque un peu parce que
quand on est quand on croise des
personnalités dans la rue enfin on peut
demander une photo on peut demander une
dédicace peut demander un autographe et
dans ce cas là on fait pas payer alors
pourquoi
c'est sa faute si je croise quelqu'un
dans la rue j'ai donc pas à chacun je le
fais c'est ça le principe c'est pas
parce qu'on vous envoie un message sur
internet qu'on va le faire ils m'ont
fait perdre à tous vous mettre dans le
même panier parce que je pense que
naquit en a qui le font parce qu'ils ont
besoin d'argent malheureusement comme
loana comme loana qui le font en le
précisant parce que je pense que c'est
important de le préciser pour des
associations si tu arrives pas tu sais
que tu le dis après quand on attaque
bien au jeu difficile de deux bras face
à hugo moi je dis pas pour jouer parce
que j'ai toute confiance moi pas le coup
de la sauce voilà j'ai tellement entendu
vérifier que la cour des comptes quand
même aux légumes comme d'habitude nous
le pays de la bien-pensance on n'a
toujours ni toujours choqué on a
toujours notre mot à dire ça vient des
états unis aux etats unis c'est grave
répandue ce sont pas du tout les mêmes
tarifs et a jamais personne ses
adhérents espèrent se balade
c'est forcément bien pas de panne et ses
serments mais pour le coup ça je trouve
ça pas mal pour le parce que moi j'en ai
moi aussi j'en ai pas fait beaucoup j'en
ai fait mais pareil pour une association
pour le
masi et j'étais même hybride récit des
trucs en ligne je vous jure c'est vrai
que s'appelle amazon et qui lutte contre
le cancer du sein c'est ce que je vais
te lancer que quand même mine de rien on
en soit à faire payer des gens cessent
alors dix justes bisous on pense à vous
dire ça moi ça fait 20 ans que j'en fais
régulièrement son prénom ceci demande ça
prend trois secondes aux gens vont des
50 balles ou 80 passé je quittais
d'après débilisant alors j'écoute un
petit peu oui mais voilà moi j'avoue que
c'est totalement d'accord doit se poser
j'ai refusé c'est même pas le fait de ce
que c'est bien de le faire ou bien c'est
juste moi tiens je te dise c'était une
question d'ego